this delicious honey butter cornbread  went viral on all of my channels so I'm  going to teach you guys how to make it  because Thanksgiving is right around the  corner and we can all use a good side so  you're going to start by mixing together  all of your dry ingredients and then  you're going to do the same for your wet  ingredients and then you're going to  pour your dry ingredients into your wet  ingredients and you're going to bake  until your cornbread is nice and golden  brown you're then going to start working  on that delicious honey butter sauce mix  that all up and then you're going to  pour that honey butter all over your  cornbread serve warm full recipes at  Tony's recipes.com enjoy your holiday